that's the limit of my German I'm sorry
I said good morning ladies and gentlemen
welcome to Gamescom it is Gamescom
everyone I am so excited for this show
to be back Gamescom is one of my
absolute favorites and of course kicking
everything off we have Jeff Keeley and
Opening Night Live the I don't know if
we've got the keeleys we've got the
Jeff's what is opening night live in the
German Jeffs the the Jeff but with a
numb layout uh I am Lucy James and
joining me in our pre and post show we
have Tomo Hussein
hi I am here loser shirt lose your mind
it's Gamescom
it's Gamescom uh it points off for zero
gem in there and also joining us is Kurt
in Davina howdy friends we're here to
talk about games at Gamescom game Keeley
Gamescom Keely yep
game will come uh so we are super
excited to be back obviously uh this is
the first in person uh show uh Opening
Night Live since 2019 there will be 30
plus games uh whether that is a a kind
of a new trailer for something that's
already been announced maybe some
announcements just kept this one a
little bit closer to the chest I feel
than he usually does with things like uh
summer game first and opening night uh
and the the game awards game awards I
need to have more coffee
um but we do have a pretty good idea of
some of the games that we are going to
be seeing today as well as some that
maybe leaked a little bit early uh this
is gonna be a live audience so I really
hope there's gonna be like some really
over enthusiastic people because that's
always my favorite heart let's go
through what we can expect to see today
uh first up a Borderlands related
announcement just before the show
started Kurt said please don't come to
me to talk about Borderlands it's okay
uh Borderlands is a series that exists
and I know it has guns and crude humor
and I know there is supposedly an
announcement that's coming today or at
least whispered of I have nothing more
to say because anything else I will say
well one show that I don't
have anything to say
because I had a very tame him I don't
want to be rude
but it's like more like Borderlands very
good very good uh Tam what do you know
about this rumored Tales from the
Borderlands yeah
yeah it got leaked in various ways
um I think I think the we're assuming
it's going to be Tales from the
Borderlands it looks very likely we
could get hit with a curveball and it's
another Borderlands movie announcement
which please God no more
um please please oh we don't need any
more of that just release the movie so
it can be over and done with it however
I will I am I am excited for um
to see what new tells from the
Borderlands stuff has they have um
cooking because for my money I think
that's one of the best parts of
Borderland entries of Borderland in the
franchise since perhaps Borderlands 2.
um it's been a long time since I've
really thoroughly enjoyed a Borderlands
game
um and and tales of Borderlands is one
of those Telltale Games from the early
days which was like it it was it was
hitting real real good um really sharp
writing really good humor and it did
some really interesting stuff with the
episodic narrative uh element of it I
think it's long overdue return
um obviously there was some tumultuous
times with you know episode of gaming
kind of like out being outgrown or like
overstaying is welcome almost and then
also you know the demise of Telltale in
a lot of ways
um but yeah I'm excited to see what this
new era of tales of the Borderland is is
going to be like um I'm Keen for it yeah
okay well apparently it was gonna it was
announced uh back in April it's gonna be
in-house at gearbox uh the Amazon
listing says October 21st uh if that is
accurate that is another big title
launching this October which for us is
very exciting for you all at home is
probably very exciting because it's been
a bit of a dry year there's been some
some really great stuff but there has
been a lot of like a lot of down time
um but I mean we we let's use this as a
nice little segue uh we mentioned
Telltale there obviously Tales from the
Borderlands was perhaps one of their
finest series uh for my money I really
enjoyed it um but we are gonna get a
look at the expanse a Telltale Games
series first look at gameplay
um is this the first like new Telltale
Game since it the the Phoenix re-emerged
From the Ashes
I believe so yes
um it's the first what major one for
sure I think there was some yeah I think
it is yeah yeah well I I'm big fan of
the expense I love the show I'm very
intrigued to see what this is going to
be but also I think you know there were
a lot of criticisms uh towards kind of
the end of era one of Telltale that all
of like their engine was outdated stuff
was slow
um it didn't necessarily you know
have the have the game feel or the the
punch anymore
um what can the what can a new game from
Telltale what does it need to have to to
excite you to okay I'll go to you first
I mean I want to take a step back and
say
regardless of whether or not I have
anything to say about Borderlands I will
want to at least positively say that we
have had a massive Gap uh in what
Telltale has done that sort of narrative
storytelling and we've had like
Whispers or at least like glimpses of
other people trying to pick it up
um the one that comes straight to mind
this year is uh and uh
as dusk Falls
um so I'm
excited before I even answer the
question I'm just excited at any
capacity whether it's Borderlands or not
I'm happy for you if you're excited for
Borderlands uh that like it's starting
to have a precedence again that we're
starting to see
Choose Your Own Adventure in narrative
based games
um so that's cool I just want to say
that I'm excited and in that expanse
even though I haven't seen expanse I
swear to God there are things I know
about that we're going to talk about
today
I'm just the expansive Borderlands are
the two things that come out of the gate
where I'm like ah those are things that
exist
but uh fourth Telltale to do something
to exist in the current state that's a
tricky question for me because I'm
pretty happy with the formula of it
although I do think as dusk Falls does a
really good job
um of
allowing it to feel more like organic
and snappy
um
yeah
and what do you reckon yeah I think it's
going to be interesting I think what
needs to happen is what kind of put
Telltale on the map to begin with I
think
um Telltale obviously started off with
at least the thing that put them on the
map was the writing in The Walking Dead
which was incredibly strong and it
distinguished Itself by having very
narrative driven focused
um strong writing at a time when a lot a
lot of other games focused entirely on
writing a narrative
um
and since then it kind of overextended
itself that you know we know that could
be this story or behind the demise of
Telltale in a lot of ways they took on
so much they were doing so much of it
and there was kind of like a fall off in
quality in a lot of the titles like it
was hit and miss on what you would get I
think the interesting thing for Telltale
new Telltale right now is it it kind of
returns to a world where the stuff that
in many ways pioneered has been
democratized and a lot of people are now
producing that kind of quality
um as thus far as being one of them
obviously we've had multiple life for
strange Titles since then and you know
indie games are a little more focused
around that stuff naturally but
there's been an uptick in um graphic
novels or like visual novel style um
games and the popularity of them so
Telltale no longer can kind of uh just
simply Coast on being the the unique uh
kind of Studio that presents this type
of game and nothing else and kind of get
away with that alone to to kind of sell
it it really needs to have super super
super strong characterization he needs
to have another Walking Dead moment
again if it's to kind of build itself
back up and it's Walking Dead I guess is
one was a big start for them and
similarly it's kind of almost a parallel
expanse is huge it's like very very
popular and
um it's known for its intricate world
and also strong writing in a lot of
cases so it's setting itself up both to
repeat that success hopefully if they
can get it right but also it potentially
could if it doesn't get it right and is
isn't hitting as hard it could stumble
and it could be a kind of false start
for the studio so what it needs to do is
really focus on ensuring that they're
writing and and the characterization is
the best it can be
absolutely agree now I'm I'm very
excited for that one like I I love the
expanse and so I really hope they can do
that one Justice uh one of the big big
games that we know we're gonna get an
extra look at today we've seen it a
couple times already last time we caught
a glimpse was at summer game Fest slash
play days the Callisto protocol from
Striking Distance Studios now Kurt are
you excited for this one
yes I am
go ahead I'm testing the water oh yes no
I know I know you're very excited about
this one you uh you and I have talked
about this one previously what do you
want to see from uh callista protocol
today I so like we've gotten the last
what they should have Summer Games Fest
was like a pretty or I mean it was a
considering that we like knew that it
was coming but we didn't know what it
was and we knew it was going to be from
like the minds of dead space and this
kind of Dead Space thing but what we saw
at simple games Fest was most certainly
like
very much this this this new kind of
spiritual thing that is very much an
exact same vein as Dead Space I'm
already sold I'm getting it so I don't
really know what more I want to see but
we I would like to see something more
linear I guess I would want to see like
the actual beat to beat gameplay we've
like we've seen lots of deaths we've
seen lots of like the signature gruesome
stuff that I could only hope to see uh
from something in the in the in the in
the world or the Mind from the minds of
dead space but uh going into into today
um yeah I would like to actually see
Hands-On gameplay I want to see what the
game feels like when it's actually being
played and moving that's what I can only
hope for yeah I I agree it's like I want
to understand
just how I'm gonna be like how much how
much I'm gonna be scared by this game
like are there gonna be these moments
where I can build all this tension and
then get you know the craps get out of
me uh Tam do you feel like with a game
like this one we're maybe seeing a
little too much of it or like or you're
you're not interested in it because
you've already seen what you need to see
from it
I think we're seeing a decent amount of
it I think we're seeing the right amount
of it for when the game is scheduled for
release like now is when they start
ramping up to get people involved I feel
like there's it's interesting because
everyone is kind of talking about how
it's a dead space alike and it's their
space their space and they've been
pretty smart and pretty so all about
ensuring that they don't show off too
much of the things that we know and love
Dead Space for the most if you know what
I mean like they show just a bare
minimum to put the thought that oh this
is a new Dead Space in our mind which is
you know a Healthcare on your character
and then lying on the ground to take you
to the right place but there's also a
lot of things that are like um iconic
about dead space that we haven't seen
much of sound design those zero g
moments and those equivalents for for
Callisto protocol
um I think we're seeing a lot of the
what they need to show to get the
marketing machine firing on as on as
many cylinders as it can without kind of
giving away too much of it and I kind of
like that approach I don't want
everything spoiled for me uh just
knowing that it's you know the the
former developers of Dead Space doing
something new is enough for me right now
um so I hope they don't overextend I
wouldn't mind seeing a little more of
the kind of like his for of all the
games at the show today this is the one
game where I'm like just take 10 minutes
and just do a small kind of walkthrough
of it you know just show us like a a
section of the game just so we can get a
good feel for it I think the the tricky
part is the atmosphere and the kind of
aesthetic of it that is harder to get a
good grasp on and short you know quick
cutaway sequences that they use for
trailers yeah I agree well I mean that
seems this is gonna be a bad segue but
you did mention that a little bit about
like games being a little Overexposed
before their release and I think uh
there is one company in particular that
kind of does do this and they've always
sort of done this and that is Warner
Brothers with the Batman games I
certainly feel like I've already seen
enough of Gotham Knights and I am
excited for Gotham Knights don't get me
wrong but we've already had like so many
character trailers we've had so much
gameplay already
um there is going to be another new
trailer today
um are you both in the same boat that I
am uh where it's kind of like I just
don't need to see this anymore yeah I
mean with that thing the game has had in
their defense or in the marketing's
defense however you want to say it uh
it's had turbulence and it's like you
know it's it's been delayed and it's
like this was announced oh God what was
it like
two years ago did we see this game tight
like it was meant to be summer last year
yes yeah and so I at this point
um
I just this is just to make sure it's
people are aware that's coming out if
you don't already know
every trailer
you know the not even a launch trailer
but you know similar vein Tam you're
you're a big bat fan how are you feeling
about Gotham Knights I've I've been very
picky about what I watch and generally
I'll only watch a trailer for this game
or a video for this game when I knew
that I was going to be writing or
um uh like talking to the developers
about it
um so I've been very fortunate in that
regard where I've kind of like avoided a
lot of the stuff
um however
I am kind of hoping that whatever they
show now
um will be uh kind of a round story more
than characters
um that that will be super super helpful
um yeah I'm excited for that
he wants to know what's going on with
Gotham Knights he's like tell me about
Gotham Knights well those of you who
don't know we Jean-Luc is making sure
this is all running correctly from the
clouds above
um yeah
you can just keep going Lucy yeah all
right uh well let's talk well that seems
like a good segue is any to go from uh a
random chaos to talking about Goat
Simulator they're skipping two they're
going straight to three
um I don't know it feels like goat
simulator was a really fun one a few
years ago but I honestly kind of dropped
off in my I don't really think about
going there very often what are you
expecting to see today another piss take
of a trailer uh oh absolutely I I have a
goat simulator like lives in this corner
of my brain because I associate it with
one this is a long story I'm not gonna
tell right now but one time I was trying
to explain this game to someone and that
when explosions happened it would say
like Michael Bay would flash on the
screen and as I was trying to tell this
to someone
um a car drove into a house down the
street from where we were and like what
what sounded like a huge explosion and
we all this is a very short shortened
idea no one was hurt but a car to drive
into a house
um and like we all ran out and like
everyone was fine the dude was driving
the car
he wasn't he was uh he wasn't all there
that's regardless everyone's healthy and
safe but I can't disassociate Goat
Simulator from that story so no matter
what we talk about today I will always
be talking about the time I was trying
to explain the game to someone and
someone drove a car into a house because
he just kind of feels appropriate that's
all anyways I'm I think it's fantastic
they skip go simulator 2. I think that's
very funny I mean like we did mention I
mentioned there that you know they kind
of took the piss out of another trailer
they
they remade the what was it the dying
light to trailer with the guy jogging
um there have been a few leaks already
uh the Dying Light 2 may come uh may
make an appearance today uh what do we
what do we think is that I mean actually
I saw a picture earlier it was on the
Xbox dashboard so
I mean at this point I'm just like I I
don't care like just uh it seems to be
the game or or it's not dying light is
it Dead Island
it is dying this is
where it was by the same developer and
then this one's had like five developers
now I'm kissing in The Run cheat Dead
Island two I'm so sorry this is where
we're at with that game where it's just
like I no one I can't even pay attention
to what that game has gone for anymore
I'm just like when you're out just let
me know until then I don't care about
anything you've got to say like say
whatever it's too much yes yeah but what
if what if the Dead Island 2
plug is actually a trailer for Goat
Simulator too
I mean if that happened I would
genuinely genuinely love that that would
be amazing I didn't I I remember I
remember when the first one came out I
remember like there was like that that
trailer was uh made of waves because it
was just it's cinematically yeah yeah it
was just it was remarkable
um and I remember coming out and it
feeling like being like a really
deflating experience like I remember
even playing it I don't even know where
I was or what time in my life a car
probably drove into a house while it was
happening
um but I just remember it not quite
having uh enough for me to remember
anything that being said we are totally
zombified out so if uh if Dead Island 2
is revealed which it looks like it's
going to be
um they really better do something
special uh they have to do something
really remarkable
um I don't know man I feel like at this
point we're almost in like sunk cost
fallacy territory where it's like that
thing's gonna come out regardless like
it could yes
it's like not not quite there yet but
like we're getting to Duke Nukem Forever
territory was just like it doesn't
matter what the stay or this game is it
just has to be released at some point I
forgot about it I made it in like in
2014.
and back then it was definitely just
more Dead Island and I think that was
when it was still with jaeger
oh yeah yeah because I mean what was
Riptide
oh that was like a spin-off one yeah
I don't remember honestly I I'm kind of
in the same boat where it's like dying
light was great and Dying Light took the
formula
and it was overall a great game really
really fun a lot of really cool systems
that interconnected with each other and
made progression feel really rewarding
but then like dying like two just wasn't
as great it was too big it was bloated
and I'm just I don't know I I know
different developers but it's the same
core kind of concept and I just kind of
feel like um
don't know dying Dead Island 2 has to do
something really really special to win
back
um speaking of Sonic Frontiers uh I'm
personally not a Sonic fan so I have not
really been involved in the discourse
around this one I took a look at it I
was like okay that looks like a
3D Sonic game that maybe I don't know
doesn't look that great uh will Premiere
new look it is playable at Gamescom and
there was a leaked trailer earlier with
a release date allegedly coming November
8th that trailer was then pulled so do
you think going the day before God of
War is gonna be good for them or not I
mean it's certainly a strategy
old strategy cotton let's see how yeah I
feel like this is like make a break for
that game like if it come if they what
they show today isn't like
markedly more exciting I feel like this
is this is the game that people are
waiting with their knives and are just
ready to like start carving up into
memes and if if they show up looking to
like the wrong kind of succulent it's
gonna get ripped apart
um and it will be like them this will be
the meme Factory for for this for this
show I mean I I always want games to
succeed
um nothing I've seen from Sonic front
here so far if it was me with excitement
I say that as a person that loves Sonic
for many many many many years
um and and still thinks like Sonic Mania
is amazing
um but if they if they show up with
half-assed like trust us we've got more
going on because that's what they've
been doing right they they show off one
element of it and it looks kind of not
good and they're like there's way more
to this than you might realize and a lot
of the people who are previewing it were
talking about we play this other part
which was great and or it was good it
was much better than that and no one's
allowed to see that if they Rock up with
that again where it's like oh we've got
this bit it looks kind of not great but
there's this other part of it that we
haven't shown you yet that is going to
be like unacceptable like it's it's now
like put up a shot up shots where we
should care and if they don't do that I
think a lot of people are just going to
check out and just use it as like that
game that way they just dunk on it
how are you feeling about Sonic
Frontiers I was just gonna ask what the
what the last Sonic game was the Sonic
fans enjoyed that wasn't Sonic Mania or
like some kind of nostalgic rebuilt or
rehash
uh Sonic Mania is is the last one like I
mean like that wasn't that that was
actually a full pledge 3D one I don't
know I mean I can't say I've enjoy it uh
Racing Transformed
I don't know you can maybe make a case
for Sonic colors but I don't know about
that anyways let's just say that because
I I haven't I don't remember the last
Sonic game that I remember people be
like this is it aside from Sonic Mania
which is just you know like although an
original game all its own is still like
constructed informed and
designed and like things from the past
that we know so that's that's it so well
we'll see we'll see about this one um
when we get a look at Sonic Frontiers
we've got just under four minutes until
the show still some games we haven't
really talked about
um we're tend to Monkey Island the
Outlast trials lies of P
um and a new Sci-Fi IP from unknown
Worlds the folks behind sub Nautica
um so I'll go to I'll go to each of you
um Tam which one of the which which game
are you excited about seeing I feel like
Liza p is very much yep Liza p is the
one that I'm excited to see
which is a collection of words I never
thought I'd ever say together but given
that Pinocchio sounds a like I really I
really hope that when you die it just
comes up on screen with I'm a real boy
yeah you're no longer a real boy
I can't what about you
so unbelievably on brand but
anything that is point-and-click
Adventure related in the mainstream
space I can't help but want to see I
want to like have a Breathe In The Many
Many Eyes of uh the mainstream Gamers of
course of course I'm excited to see more
of the return to Monkey Island and it's
beautiful art style that I think is
absolutely fantastic
cunning hostile don't know what people
online are talking about it's beautiful
unique people need to chill out it looks
awesome
all right we go two and a half minutes
uh what are your wild card predictions
what is the game that hasn't been
announced hasn't leaked that you would
love to see today
oh I don't think we're gonna have many
of them if any at all um I constantly
tweet at Young Jeff Keeley to be like
where's that Elven ring DLC Jeff where
is it at huh I know he does like I do it
just to annoy him at this point one day
Jeff Keely is gonna just physically
smack me one day when I'm he's just
gonna be like I've had enough of you I'm
just gonna hit me imagine getting
blocked by Jeff oh God imagine imagine
that I think I I will say like there is
a decent ah
there's like it's 50 50 on whether uh
uh than the new um Team Cherry game I've
just gone out my head a hollow Knight
silk song wherever that appears here I
feel like it's more likely to appear
um in in
um the game awards but there's decent
charts it could it could show up here
you never know a few days from now
true
I don't know I I feel like that's more
of a game awards thing yeah I think I
don't know maybe your biowares will be
at the game awards
um
stuff for next year I don't I honestly
don't know I'm thinking like I know
there is an Xbox like Xbox obviously
there Gamescom and one of the games that
I'm really excited about seeing more of
this year is definitely pentiment a game
that I have to say like that because
it's such a satisfying name Kurt what
about you
Jeff Keely is going to walk out on stage
with
the most marvelous sneakers you've ever
seen and he's gonna
hold on and he's gonna lift the soul up
to the camera and it's gonna say no
Elden ring DLC but then he's gonna do a
double kick and then the other one's
gonna say goal Reaver is coming back and
that's it wow wow
that would be great yeah I know you're
gonna say like he'd lift his shoe and it
just says Andy on the bottom
and then he just flops over because
there's loads of people looking at him
and he's coming no I don't know I mean
yeah we have all that exciting news from
the embracer group
um there are you know
I don't know they've got Lord of the
Rings now I'm very intrigued to see if
that pops I mean it's very very early
there are a few Lord of the Rings games
in development already but I don't know
I'm intrigued to see what we're gonna
get from this year's show we've got
about 20 seconds so uh remember folks uh
to watch along here on the stream we
will be back at the end of Opening Night
Live to uh talk about all the big
announcements so make sure you stay
tuned enjoy
um and you know have a good time and
we'll be right here
over to Jeff watching
please welcome to the stage the creator
of the game awards Jeff Keeley
[Music]
foreign
oh my God hello everybody how you doing
it is so great to have a live crowd with
us here at Cologne Germany for Gamescom
2022. I'm Jeff Keely and I gotta say I
am so excited to be here with you we did
this in 2019 live in person in Germany
in the past two years we had to do it
virtually from Los Angeles and in 2020
the first show that my team did together
live was that August Gamescom and we
connected with all of you virtually and
the fact that we're back here in person
I don't ever take this for granted
before so uh guys are you ready for a
fun show
well I gotta say we have a lot of great
stuff for you tonight we have tons of
world premieres the entire industry has
come together to showcase the future for
you we've got games like Sonic Frontiers
the Callisto protocol
outlash trials Hogwarts Legacy Gotham
Knight and a lot of surprises of things
that we didn't talk about in advance so
we've got some good stuff for you
tonight here at Gamescom and I can't
wait to get started we've got two hours
of stuff so should we just get right to
it
all right
I love the Roar of a live crowd and
because we got a live crowd we gotta
surprise you with some stuff tonight too
so let's start things off with our first
world premiere it's a new world from a
brand new team that has a bold Vision
let's check this out
[Music]
we want the community to build this we
wanted to be their worlds we want them
to tell their stories in their game I
think it's human nature to navigate on a
territory to find a place where we're
free to explore to be creative and to
share amazing experiences
the goals are to make an experience
that's unlike any other which is such an
exciting thing to be part of I think
ultimately like that's kind of been the
big ambition is to create this kind of
like open world that can be built out in
every direction I think it's every day
as a new discoveries and it's constantly
growing we've put a lot of focus I think
on the current side guys and what it
means to represent yourself digitally
this is more than a game it's a labor of
love it's a labor of passion
dream is to create a whole new world for
the next generation of Gamers and I
think that we've we've kind of captured
that players will play a massive part in
this it's not going to be just our game
it's not going to be just what we decide
to do with it there's something in it
that will get definitely appeal to you
no matter what it is that you love to do
the really thrilling aspect of all this
is that people can get to see what we're
doing for the first time I'm just so
excited for people to see what we've
been spending the last five years
pouring our hearts and souls into and
I'm excited to see how they feel about
it even though they will have to wait
just a little bit longer everywhere has
become more than just a video game for
us
today we're delighted to give you a peek
behind the curtain of what we've been
working on
[Music]
true
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
there you go everywhere and I'm sure
you've got a ton of questions and
joining me now from Builder rocketboy is
Adam Whiting to hopefully answer some of
those because we're a little confused
but we want to know a lot about this so
tell us uh everywhere what kind of game
is this what can you tell us Adam well
firstly going to say it's really
exciting to just be here and we've been
looking forward to coming out of stealth
mode and really delighted to start the
conversation today here at Gamescom
now I won't be able to reveal everything
but what I can say is that really we're
not trying to make a normal game I think
the scope and ambition of this project
are quite unlike anything else we want
to build a whole new world for gamers
and not just a place to play but watch
share create hang out with your friends
and so much more well I gotta say uh the
end of the trailer I think we all were
taken aback by whoa change outside this
seems totally different what is that
part of everywhere what can you tell us
well that's one of the many surprises
we've got in store for players I mean we
are passionate about making games and
telling stories but ultimately we made
everywhere to be a place where a place
can make their own experiences be who
they want to be and tell their own
stories but we're still passionate about
making immersive and cinematic
experiences the players can just get
lost in and enjoy I guess you say we
want people to have their cake and eat
it and everywhere is the place that can
happen all right well it definitely a
bold vision for what you're doing here
uh the other question I'm sure we're all
wondering is we didn't see a date on the
trailer any sense of when we're going to
get to play this thing where are you at
in development well I'm delighted to say
that we aim to have everywhere in the
hands of players in 2023 but we've got
many more things to show and tell over
the coming months and we're really
excited for you to sign up on our
website everywhere.game but really today
was just a sneak peek behind the curtain
to see what the team has been so hard at
work on and we're really excited to get
this in the hands of players as soon as
possible amazing well Adam thank you for
sharing the reveal here at Gamescom it's
awesome to have so many European Studios
on stage and tonight we've got a lot of
European students are going to reveal
their games for the first time and right
now we're going to move to another world
premiere announcement
[Applause]
[Music]
I must not fear
foreign
killer
fear is The Little Death that brings
total obliteration
I will face my fear
I will permit it to pass over and
through me
and when it has gone past I will turn
the inner eye to see its path
remember it's gone there will be nothing
thank you
only I will remain
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
trust me the fun is just beginning
tonight all right how many of you out
there are fans of PlayStation
well we've got a fun surprise for you I
said PlayStation what can we do for all
the fans come together here at Gamescom
and right now I'm honored to share this
Global PlayStation announcement with you
right here at Gamescom
trouble
[Music]
PlayStation
there you go the Dual sense Edge it's a
high performance Ultra customizable
wireless PlayStation 5 controller
designed by PlayStation and you see
there you can have your own custom
control profiles uh customized to your
play style if you guys want to learn
more about the brand new controller you
can head to Playstation blog and thanks
to PlayStation for sharing that
announcement with us here at Gamescom
all right next up the Callisto protocol
you guys hyped for that game
thank you
well joining me now is Glenn Schofield
from Striking Distance uh Glenn we are
so excited about this game coming out in
December you came all the way over in
the middle of development to Gamescom we
really appreciate it uh how is the
response been to Callisto so far man
Jeff the response has been fantastic for
a new IP I couldn't ask for anything
more uh so I want to thank the fans and
uh I want to thank my team for uh just
really killing it and it's great to be
back at Gamescom man you know
well you got some good stuff for the
fans and we're going to get to that in a
second
um you brought some gameplay we saw some
great stuff at summer game Fest you
brought more now what are we going to
see today yeah you've got uh some uh
live gameplay uh we've got two sections
the first one is going to show some uh
some crazy combat and uh the second one
is uh something new uh from the game a
little different than what we've shown
with a uh pretty crazy ending
yes it is you guys are gonna love this
uh one thing I want to ask you about was
you're known certainly in the team for
your work on Dead Space in that game we
love the Strategic dismemberment I
understand you're kind of one-upping
things for this game well we got this
rememberment and we've shown the gore
system
um and today we're going to show a
couple new things uh including one that
we're showcasing called mutations so uh
the enemies May sometimes have these
tentacles that come out and if you don't
shoot them take them out on time uh this
guy in real time is going to mutate in
front of you into something bigger
better faster meaner and he's going to
be taking you out it's uh it's pretty
cool well this is one of my most
anticipated games it's coming out this
December Glenn thanks to you and the
team for putting this together let's
take a look at brand new gameplay from
the Callisto protocol
thank you
all right
foreign
[Applause]
all right that's pretty good right
we got lots more coming for you but
right now I want to introduce my co-host
for onl Melly Melly welcome to onl
thanks Jeff I was so excited to be here
at Gamescom hello everybody I'm your
guide for tonight for all the happenings
around Gamescom and I'm really really
excited to be here because the heart of
gaming is beating once again and game
devs and Publishers from all around the
world are making their way to Cologne to
show you hundreds of new games so if you
if you're not here yet and still can
come by make sure to drop by and if you
can't make sure to to drop by next year
because it is definitely worth a visit
and one of the highlights we have this
year is we actually have the largest in
the area ever bringing visitors and devs
closer together than everywhere anywhere
else in the world and you can meet the
makers of the most original and
fantastic and creative games here and if
you're not here and if you can't make it
here do not worry you can also go check
out the Indie Arena Booth online at
gamescom.global Jeff it's back to you
thank you Molly and you'll be with us
all night we've got Gamescom Awards to
come and other things too but let's get
right back to the world premieres this
next one is one you've been waiting for
for a long time to see let's take a look
at this brand new world premiere
[Music]
age of the cruelest Tyranny man finally
defeated it's Overlord
the gods do not fall
forever
the champions of War United
and began the Eternal watch over their
Thailand's colossal remains
for some forces even death
cannot end
but now eons later
the Fallen Gods influence pervades the
world again
corrupting even sworn enemies join
joins accursed Lords of the fallen and
damn Humanity
to a new age of devastation
though from these Darkest Days
[Music]
arise to defy the gods one must embrace
the darkness
[Music]
the Lords of the Fallen
wishlist now
that's right they dropped the two uh the
the Lords of the Fallen all right now
it's time for another new game
announcement the sequel to a game that
redefined the term couch Co-op check
this out
[Music]
are you struggling
missing your regular farts
have you tried going online
visit exotic destinations
move your dreams whoever you are
apply today no skills no worries
everybody's welcome you're hired
open a door of New Opportunities
work alone or with a friend or two or
more
do it
move locally or connect together online
thank you
yeah
nice one
coming 2023
[Applause]
.
yes it's time to step into the Potter
verse you guys excited for Hogwarts
Legacy
well it is coming out in February of
2023 and tonight at Gamescom we've got
the brand new trailer for you to take a
look at I don't want to say much and
spoil much this is an incredible trailer
I hope you enjoy it
[Music]
the more we know about Salazar Slytherin
and the dark arts the best prepared will
be
if either of you uses dark magic I will
notify the Headmaster immediately
unforgivable curses are so named for a
reason a spell that could save your life
shouldn't be unforgivable the dark
Hearts seem harmless until it's too late
none of us will be able to avoid dark
magic forever
up to us I can
go
cast it on you
I'm ready
you've made your choice
what have the two of you dogs
[Music]
foreign
that's right it's time to step into the
world to Borderlands now joining me is
the founder of gearbox Entertainment
Company Randy Pitchford Randy great to
see you here thanks for the intro uh
Jeff I think a lot of these guys
probably know me from my work at gearbox
creating Borderlands any Borderlands
fans in the house
well I got good news I know uh some of
you hardcore folks saw the leak uh but
I'm here to officially announce new
Tales from the Borderlands tell us about
this we remember Tales from the
Borderlands this is new Tales of
Airlines this is new characters new
story it is you know I loved the
original game and so that's why we got
some of the original storytellers and
writers that were back in the day at
Telltale and developed an all-new
storyline with all new characters uh
created uh uh with a production from
gearbox Studio Quebec uh it's an all new
experience and uh we're here to show it
for the first time today you guys want
to check it out
Let's Dance coming soon too right that's
right uh coming in October of this year
October this year all platforms awesome
well let's take a look Randy this is
exciting new Tales from the Borderlands
first at Gamescom
[Music]
most stories in the Borderlands start
bloody
they end bloody too
sometimes politics to change the Galaxy
is a trio of losers trying to get
through a bad day
we are in the middle of a TV or Invasion
leave immediately this area is now under
Studio jurisdiction they think there was
a vault key being kept on the station if
we can find whatever's in that Vault
before Titi or does we can change our
lives
like really bad
did you has many gods talking guns guns
with legs I'm gonna blast you freaking
bad yeah shut up Richard
ain't nobody stopping me I always wanted
to change the universe for the better
and now we are some tan but more
importantly we'll be drowning in
why are you people like this
if you happen to see any corpses along
the way uh don't worry about them
they're just uh
yeah don't worry about them
come back to the city and join the
deadliest spectacle of this season
I'm gonna tell you a story about a
species that survived millennia
Homo neanderthalensis homo rhodesians
homo erectus all of them wiped out by
the deadliest species of all
us
I am Astrid this is the new Arena and my
advice for you
stay alive
every day you fight for survival but
today you fight for Glory
anyone can be a warrior What Makes You
Different is the spirit of a champion
Red Bull gives you wings
so you want to join me
sign up and be a part of my crew in
Tortuga
product not yet rated
foreign
[Music]
let them come and see
they do they do them
one Shackled from Hope
Act
Ive
who they are
because only in the end
[Music]
hello again this Saturday the game score
Awards will be handed out to the winners
of the best games on the show floor only
submitted Games showing at Gamescom will
be eligible to be nominated and the
awards will be streamed on all Gamescom
channels so make sure to tune in but
tonight I'm allowed to hand out four
Awards I'm very very excited about that
and I would say let's jump straight into
it starting with the most Wanted PC game
here are your nonies
[Music]
metal helsinger
System Shock
[Music]
Warhammer 40 000 dark tide
and the winner is Metal Health singer
and here to accept the award is Sheila
victim executive producer at The
Outsiders the stage is yours
thank you so much wow this is a lot of
people I was practicing my speech a lot
but of course you know when it's
um as much people as there is right now
you'll blank
um but I want to say that I am honored
to receive this award on behalf of my
team the team behind metal is an amazing
bunch of people that I'm so lucky to be
working with every day and the truth is
making games is super hard when I
started out I don't think I really
realize how hard and what I learned is
that focusing on compassion kindness and
empathy just as much as any other craft
in games would be the key to successful
game development and it's precisely
those qualities that my team possess and
why I'm so privileged to be working with
them every day I love you guys at home I
miss you so much so what I want to say
to you my industry friends and
colleagues is treat each other with
heart kindness and respect every day
make games with Humanity thank you so
much
congratulations once again
and Jeff back to you thank you Molly
well the world premier train keeps going
it's time to move to the world of Sonic
any Sonic Hedgehog fans out there
Sonic has had a pretty good year with
the Sonic 2 movie which was a ton of fun
earlier this year Well Sonic Frontiers
is in development and we've got a brand
new trailer for you and confirmation of
the release date too check this out
hey
[Music]
submit
your Reckless actions endanger the world
[Music]
foreign
there you go it is coming this year
Sonic frontiers all right well now
another European Studio wanted to use
Gamescom o l as a platform to announce
another narrative experience this comes
from
a French Studio check this out
[Music]
I believe so many things behind us
objects
memories
mistakes
[Music]
they sink in time
touch the bottom and go to sleep
silence is full of ghosts
[Music]
and here
voices can only come from the deep
deep under the waves
[Music]
[Applause]
guys
it's time for the goats ready for some
goats
no live goats today but we are here to
talk about Goat Simulator 3 we got to
announce this back at summer game Fest
and now it's time to see the gameplay of
Goat Simulator 3 for the first time
let's check this one out
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
November 17th that has literally about
everything you could imagine in it uh
Goat Simulator three all right A lot of
people ask me how I got started in the
industry and what I loved doing when I
was a kid with my brother we would play
PC adventure games and I grew up playing
classic LucasArts and Sierra adventure
games you guys remember Monkey Island by
chance
well I am so excited because there is a
new Monkey Island in development right
now Ron Gilbert the series Creator is
back you may have heard about it return
to Monkey Island and tonight at Gamescom
I am so excited that we get to announce
the release date or actually I don't we
get to go to Stan to tell us the release
date check this out
[Music]
Hello friends it's your old pal stand
coming to you through the magic of
marketing to let you know that your
search for Quality entertainment is
about to bear fruit but I wouldn't be
doing my job if I just drop the details
on you without a little build up I I
want you to see the kind of fine dining
establishments you'll be visiting like
this one get lost
and if escapism is your cup of flavor
you can't do much better than this
exotic and extremely remote island stay
back how did you find me
return to Monkey Island launches
September 19th which happens to be
International Talk Like a Pirate Day but
you don't have to wait you can order it
right now before it's even out something
we in the marketing industry call a
pre-order as a bonus I'm ready to unload
this shipment of beautiful horse armor
to anyone who pre-orders return to
Monkey Island it'll look fantastic in
your inventory wait you missed a spot
I've gotta go now I've got a lot of
irons and a lot of fires you know how it
is but I'll be back to steal every scene
I'm in and return to Monkey Island I'll
see you there
all pre-order customers will receive the
exclusive horse armor item in their
inventory please note that the horse
armor has no practical use in game and
in no way will contribute to the
gameplay puzzles or Narrative of return
to Monkey Island
oh my gosh a month away and I love the
horse armor does absolutely nothing it
just sits in your inventory return to my
gallery cannot wait for that all right
now let's turn to the world of unknown
Worlds the creators of subnautica as
we've teased they are here today at
Gamescom to unveil a brand new IP and
it's a departure from subnautica it's a
brand new turn-based Sci-Fi game and uh
we're gonna reveal it for the first time
right here actually special guest is
let's check this out
foreign hi I'm Brandon Sanderson you
might know me as the author of the
mistborn series The Stormlight Archive
or as the guy who finished Robert
Jordan's Wheel of Time over the last few
years I've been working closely with my
friends at unknown worlds on the
exciting project we're revealing today
you of course know unknown worlds for
creating immersive and Fantastical
worlds like the incredible subnautica
series when they reached out to me I was
absolutely thrilled to help craft the
expansive sci-fi Universe in which their
next game is set this secret has been a
hard one to keep and we're so excited to
finally show you what we've created
together so without further Ado this is
moonbreaker
let us keep this civilized
welcome to the party
until the end
stay alive
grenades anyone
they'll never see this coming
I taste their Panic
The Game Stop This Treasury
all right
I've Got The Crowd Goes Wild
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
worlds is Charlie Cleveland Charlie
moonbreaker it's real and it's so
different than subnautica so yes it is
this departure uh you guys like to kind
of reinvent yourselves every game right
yeah so people thought we were kind of
crazy for making subnautica after making
natural selection we went from a
strategy shooter to a pacifist
underwater Game survival uh so I feel
like we've done this before we you know
we love changing genres but I'm hoping
you know our subnautica fans will still
come along for playing a digital
Miniatures game I hope it's so cool a
digital Miniatures game uh everyone
loves Miniatures but how do you
translate that into gameplay what is the
gameplay of this game so uh we're kind
of channeling like uh Guardians of the
Galaxy or Firefly kind of feel
so you can see that from the colorful
art style we have so you choose a
captain and ten crew and you build a
roster kind of like a traditional
Miniatures game and every unit in the
game is really like strange and special
and kind of game breaking so
um yeah you deploy units and you move
them around on the battlefield and you
get all these crazy game changing Powers
kind of like Hearthstone meets x-com
kinda well I I love I mean you see the
gameplay here it looks great and uh it's
coming soon as we said in the September
so you're not really actually not going
to wait long but the thing I want to get
to is the paint painting of Miniatures
which we saw teas of in the trailer and
I know you actually painting was
cathartic for you sort of during the
pandemic right yeah so the painting I
mean you can't have a Miniatures game
without painting and during the lockdown
I just found myself like learning to
draw and just like just zoning out and
feeling really relaxed when the world
was basically falling apart around us
and we really tried to capture that
feeling it's not like Photoshop or like
special technical tools or anything like
that you we just simulate washes dry
brushing we've got decals um this feels
like you're actually painting a real
miniature and I have to say because
everyone is surprised by it like all the
Miniatures you see painted in the game
are all painted with the tool so it's
like actually pretty powerful amazing
well it's so cool that you're revealing
it here and it's gonna it's playable at
Gamescom it is it's here you guys are
the first ones to play it wow and uh oh
yeah it's more
we're over in the Crafton Booth okay
craft and booth and for everyone else
around the world they're not wait long
right yes we'll be on Steam play test in
September we have a couple open weekends
and then we're going to be launching
um into steam Early Access September
29th so it's really close only a month
away Moon record Charlie thank you so
much for coming all the way out here
thank you I know you had a tough my
pleasure thank you everyone all right
Charlie Cleveland with unknown worlds
thank you so much Charlie
and now it's time to reveal another game
with a very catchy tune in the trailer
check this out
[Music]
foreign
too much
[Music]
inspired by The Familiar story of
Pinocchio lies of p is a new action
souls-like game that is coming out from
Neil Wiz and you guide Pinocchio on his
unrelenting journey to become human this
game looks absolutely great and we've
got a brand new Gameplay trailer to show
you and this game is also coming to Xbox
game pass on day one let's check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
can you hear me
this reaches you
this city is falling apart chaos
Madness that
and there might be no going back
[Music]
that you can change that
it depends on the choice you make
truth
or lie
too much of you
but I don't have a
foreign
finally
we meet
son
[Music]
the stage is set
the light shines brightest in the
darkest of times
all right buddy I'm here for you don't
worry
thank you
don't give up
[Music]
full of fail
foreign
destiny
[Applause]
hey you
yes you do you have fun
[Music]
fear of missing Gamescom
relax games come this everywhere you
want
games come now register now
that's right all the fun of Gamescom is
available from wherever you are online
obviously and well in case you're
wondering who that little guy is that's
EPI and he's on a mission to save the
games Converse from the evil future and
if you want to help him check out the
Epic section at gamescom.global you can
solve quests and win prizes so take part
and help Epi to save the games Converse
but first I want to tell you more about
some of the great program we have for
this week and it's quite a schedule so
please bear with me there is for example
the Gamescom Studio by IGN featuring
Game spotlights deaf interviews and all
insights into this year's Gamescom so
please make sure to check that out so
you don't miss anything and also the
awesome Indie showcases Back featuring
the newest most original crazy indie
games here on Friday afternoon at 5 30
p.m CST and I'm really looking forward
to it and some something I'm really
looking forward to to is is is the is
the cosplay contest on Sunday where the
super creative cosplay Community takes
center stage and this is absolutely one
of my favorites so make sure to not miss
it out it is definitely worth the watch
and for more updates follow at Gamescom
on all platforms and well now it is
almost time to introduce our next guest
but sadly she couldn't make it since
she's that far away so let's see she
sent us a video and I would say let's
have a look
hello Gamescom I'm Isa astronaut
Samantha christopheretti currently
flying at around 27 000 kilometers an
hour 400 kilometers above your head on
board of the International Space Station
today I come to you to say Bravo to the
games industry
we see how many space games you've been
creating recently Transmissions you send
your players on aren't just great fun
they create curiosity interest and the
love of space exploration in Gamers
around the world
as we look towards returning to the moon
and on to Mars with our ambitious
terranova program
Humanity's space flight capabilities
will be in part thanks to the games
industry and who knows perhaps even you
will be among us here at visa for the
journey
exploring space virtually isn't just
great fun it's setting real world
impacts that lead us all closer to the
Stars
so on behalf of everyone at Esa Bravo
keep creating keep innovating and keep
playing
this is ISA astronaut Samantha
Christopher wishing everyone a wonderful
Gamescom from the International Space
Station
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
when we were looking at games for
Gamescom Opening Night Live one of the
things I was most impressed with this
year is there a lot of European Studios
that want to debut games here and also a
lot of brand new IP brand new worlds and
we're going to introduce one of those to
you right now and I think you're going
to get pretty excited about it check out
this world premiere
[Music]
foreign
the sand has memories
memories of our past
when Gods warped this world and our
heroes stood amongst them
but the gods vanity grew and in their
struggle
we were Cast Away
[Music]
stories remain
sand
in the ruins of this shattered broken
world
[Music]
foreign
s we endure
we can stand for ourselves
face gods
[Applause]
Atlas Fallen coming in 2023
now a classic strategy game that I
remember playing in the late 90s is
Homeworld anyone else play that back in
the day
Great PC space RTS well a brand new home
world is coming out next year uh and
we've got a brand new look at some new
gameplay from Homeworld let's check it
out
[Music]
it was a simple perimeter scan
scoring resources but we were ambushed
by Kalan Raiders I
missile crickets were a different story
the man got clever One Wing used cover
to keep himself safe on approach
[Music]
while another group found a tunnel in
the structure to sneak behind them
up let's do this
it worked but just before a carrier
battle group arrived
we scrambled bombers
perfect for attacking Capital ships
we protected the resourcers while they
hauled in the goods which meant we could
roll out assault rates
the Raiders weren't pushovers but
command countered their hit and run
tactics
the way their carrier exploded
and we even grabbed a little souvenir
that missile frigate is ours now
[Music]
Homeworld 3 in the first half of 2023.
now today is a big day speaking of
Threes because it's the version 3.0
update to gentian impact which is an
incredible action RPG from hoyoverse
well today we've got an exclusive new
look at version 3.0 in the new
rainforest Nation as well as a sneak
peek of a mysterious ancient
civilization and settlement that is
found deep inside the desert let's take
a look at this world premiere
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
better Germany
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
what an absolutely beautiful game and
that's not all from hoyoverse because
they also have honkai star rail in
development It's a grand Interstellar
adventure with strategic turn-based
combat and now we're going to take a new
look at the story and Adventure that
awaits you in honkai Star rail
foreign
[Music]
hello again it is now time for our next
Gamescom award and here are your
nominees for the Most Wanted Microsoft
Xbox game
[Music]
the dark pictures The Devil in Me
the last case of Benedict Fox
[Music]
medal helsinger
and the winner is the last case of
Benedict Fox
and here to accept the award is barte
iglesiakovsky creative director at plot
twist
congratulations thank you it's quite of
a shocker for us we just love good Metro
in Vania games and we are working hard
on making benefits Benedict Fox just
that and I would like to thank Xbox team
for their support and Rogue team for
being the best publisher ever and
especially I would like to thank my team
in Krakow they are crazy talented and my
hands hold the award but their hands
make the game Tinker with Ambassador
thank you congratulations once again the
last case of Benedict Fox and Jeff back
to you
thank
you thank you very much Melly uh anyone
here a fan of Justin Roiland
Rick and Morty well he's got a brand new
game which you may have seen at Xbox's
show in June called high on life it is
coming to Xbox and Game Pass in December
and they wanted to send us just a great
gameplay clip uh you're gonna enjoy this
uh talking guns in a boss fight and
that's all I'm gonna say to set this up
I think you're gonna really this is a
trip check this out World premiere of
high on life
foreign
[Music]
no
[__] you
are you even a real Bounty Hunter
this isn't so gross you even went in
there
yeah so stop diving into it
he's filling the place with sludge stay
in the air
you better not fall in hey I'm still
here you can still use me if you want
I can deflict attacks did you know that
not just all about stabbing well I'm
mostly all about stabbing and tethering
but I can also deflect attacks
I'll slice in the [__] dab I'll cut
their [__] heads off oh [__] no
rip their limbs or [__] do everything
wrong in a [__] cut right into them
I'll cut their [__] [__] off and
eat it you know this sludge matches your
toxic personality [__] off
a good one surprise
[Music]
incoming laser
laser just for you
hey you're just as nice and Squishy on
the inside as the rest of them let me
out of bounty hunter
wow we're having our first real boss
fight together
oh
my God
I'm the strongest out of all the torb
Clones
I'm impressed you made it this far my
ex-solders are extreme strong honestly I
don't think they were we're new at this
and it was pretty easy to kill them all
if I'm going out I'm taking you with me
just stay alive I think she's basically
done for it
thank you
[Music]
uh do you see that
what when
um
what is it
wait what are you don't eat that come on
dude dude you know she's gonna eat it
what
yep
no
told you
gross
foreign
you've been selected from among
thousands of candidates hey cutter to
join the lynx family you're from earth
right this is more than just a job it's
an opportunity you ever miss it
links making the worlds a better place
[Music]
what they say about work and space is
true
[Music]
there's something real special here
you don't have power here you never will
look around you
we're expendable
in a tray wagon
between the ribs of a ship gaze out of
the rest of the human race buzzing in
the distance
that's when the sky
fills up with flames
that's the way things go
[Music]
bring it together now
now we're talking
about
[Music]
and we bring it all together now you
gotta help me rescue my friends
[Music]
you go
bring it together now
[Music]
first announce back at the game awards
telltale's next project is based on the
Prime video series The expanse well we
showed you a little bit of the trailer
at the game awards to set up the world
now you're going to get a first Glimpse
at the gameplay with this behind the
scenes clip enjoy
foreign
ers
the expanse is obviously one of those
universes that has a ton of opportunity
to sell great stories one of the things
I'm super excited about is the zero g
stuff that we've been doing a big part
of when we're making the game not only
are we thinking about the characters we
also have to think about how can we
evolve the genre in anywhere that will
make players excited to be part of this
universe and feel like they're engaging
in something rather than just being a
passive audience member you'll figure
something out
I know you will
it's actually been a really interesting
thing as an actor to explore some of her
more vulnerable sides that by the time
we meet her in the series they've been
cauterized
Big Score driver
it's the greatest score any scavenger
has ever come across
you'll need me if you want any chance of
unloading it
the craziness of exploded ship that now
constitutes several parts in a mass you
can move among and balancing that out
against almost like you're Excavating
story that's a personal story those are
people those are characters and you are
now among
they're ghosts whatever they were doing
right before they died being a scavenger
pretty dark job
really excited about how it feels to
both play and experience the story in
the game
[Music]
so get to it
speaking of adapting things from one
medium to another here's a film
adaptation that into a game which I
don't think you would have ever expected
check this out
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
goats killer clowns we got it all
tonight in Opening Night Live now we've
got another brand new game announcement
from a European publisher for a Sci-Fi
Action Adventure here we go
[Music]
we always wondered if we're alone in the
universe
we observed and explored but found
nothing
until now
[Music]
it has been six months since the alien
object known as the metahedrons suddenly
appeared above Earth's atmosphere
[Music]
personal lock sentient contact
assessment and response time
[Music]
Kate we have an issue
power supply failing
sensors offline I'm switching to backup
generators
[Music]
[Applause]
now we're going to talk about Gamescom
goes green which is an initiative that
has made Gamescom the first
climate-friendly gaming event in the
world the core event and this show
Opening Night Live I'm happy to say are
100 climate neutral for the first time
and that's something we all should be
very proud of
you guys are part of that too now as
part of this initiative Gamescom along
with the United Nations environmental
program initiative playing for the
planet are going to give out the first
ever Gamescom goes green award to the
best sustainability concept from an
exhibitor here at Gamescom and the
nominees are Microsoft Xbox Yuki and the
Indie Arena booth and to find out the
winner let's turn it over to melee thank
you thank you Jeff and yes the winner of
this year's Gamescom ghost green award
is Yuki
and here to accept the award is Dr Joe
twist CEO of Yuki congratulations thank
you so much thank you Gamescom for this
wonderful award it's brilliant to be
recognized thank you to the Yuki team
who worked so hard every day to be
greener and thank you to the un's
playing for the planet Alliance for
inspiring us to change you know it's so
fantastic to see these amazing game
worlds that we're going to play in over
the next year but you know we only have
one planet to live on
and we only have one lifetime to make a
change and to protect that planet so
that we can continue to play our games
so everybody whether you're a player or
a business can make one small change
starting tomorrow and together
we can play more games together and save
the planet thank you very much thank you
Joe and congratulations once again to
Yuki and remember it is not only the
organizers or exhibitors that can go
green all of you can also make a change
by donating to the Gamescom Forest so
plan your games come true today Jeff
back to you awesome thank you very much
Melanie congratulations to Yuki uh now
it's time to announce a brand new game
from a new studio of Industry veterans
working on an ambitious new RPG here's
the first tease
[Music]
foreign
Crux of reality
there exists two lies
one before the shadow
and one behind the eye
[Music]
lots of news here at Gamescom all right
let's talk about Xbox and Age of Empires
4 that continues to expand now we have
news on the next civilizations joining
the battle as free DLC if you want to
learn more about what's happening with
Age of Empires 4 tune into the Xbox
Booth stream for developer interviews on
Thursday but right now here's that
announcement from Age of Empires 4.
foreign
[Music]
must find their own path to Victory
whether you strike from afar or Ambush
up close the malians will use witch and
strategy to outmaneuver their opponents
and gain the advantage on the
battlefield
thank you
with powerful Siege tools and the
ability to Rally large formations the
Ottomans can keep the pressure on to
bring down their enemies defenses
[Music]
when the drums of War beat how will you
emerge Victorious
history is in the making
and your place in it has just begun
[Applause]
time to head to Gotham you guys excited
for Gotham Knights
well you don't have to wait long it is
coming this October and Batgirl
Nightwing Robin and red hood are going
to take over in Gotham Knights you're
probably wondering about the story who
are the villains well we've got a lot to
share in this brand new trailer and also
some exciting news the release date it's
going to be a little earlier than you
expected
check this out
[Music]
Jim Gordon never gave up on anything
that's why Gotham City is still here
that's why I'm still here
and I've known for a while now that
someday like him I'd have to work with
you
I've seen plenty of criminals in my
career but
nothing could have prepared me for this
[Music]
well well if it isn't brat girl
Gotham City
blood in the water
sharks are circling
they're all making their move play nice
but we aren't going to give up
a storm has rated over got them nothing
can stop it
see you later for me
I need your help
your skills
your knowledge
your adaptability
foreign
you got my back
is based on a true story of my story
so the world will feel the cold as I do
I got one last little surprise for you
come to watch the show Red Hood
nah I'm just here to kick your ass
pretty good trailer right October 21st
now for Gotham Knights all right now
it's time to announce a brand new game
from a new studio the global
announcement of the ambitious new
adventure game developed by Everstone
games it's called where wins meet it's
an interactive open world RPG featuring
action adventure and martial arts set in
a turbulent time in the northern Song
Dynasty the combat looks really cool
check out this announcement of where
winds meet
[Music]
foreign
please
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I just wanna
foreign
[Music]
s meet again so much new IP tonight it's
really cool all right back when we
started o l in 2019 a very special guest
joined me here in person uh to close the
show and this year when I told them that
we were going to be back here live in
person he said well I got to take part
in some way uh so please uh say hello to
my good friend hideo Kojima Mr Kojima
thank you Jeff
yeah game is going on
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
live we announced Park Beyond from
Olympic entertainment and Bandai Namco
and this year they've got an awesome uh
Booth experience for those of you here
in person and for those of you at home
we've got a brand new trailer that shows
you more of this incredible amusement
park simulation game
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
great job guys this has a lot of
potential
couldn't we go A Step Beyond
[Music]
[Applause]
what about you
will you go beyond your imagination
of Beyond coming soon
so much fun I love the diversity of
games we have here Amusement Proxima I
love theme park back in the day great to
see that's coming out uh from limbic and
Bandai Namco all right now it's time to
share another special announcement here
at Gamescom not a game but a concept car
that's right it's here at Gamescom and I
got to catch up with Oliver Heimer the
head of mini design
let's check it out
all right I'm over here at the mini
Booth with Oliver this is the mini
concept aceman reveal this looks so cool
I glad you like it well let's take a
look and learn more in this trailer
[Music]
foreign
for you all over uh first of all I want
to ask you about this partnership uh a
car with gaming features and Pokemon how
did this come together yeah first of all
let's talk about Gamescom you know
Gamescom is
um one of the core events of femdom pop
culture and as we are ourselves are a
part of that pop culture we don't want
to miss out such a great event and the
Pokemon company International and we
have a lot in common we're both iconic
Brands and mini is more than a car it's
a character your partner to explore the
world and the world of Pokemon is full
of unique characters with special powers
so we share a love for distinctive
design and strong values
I'm going to ask you your favorite
Pokemon in a minute but first I want to
ask about the gaming features we saw a
little bit in the trailer tell us break
it down why does this appeal to gamers
so first of all it's all about the ace
men's gaming features it's designed to
be playful as the brand is the Pokemon
mode welcomes you inside of the car and
then you can connect your gaming console
to your mini and all you'll notice it's
a lot of details referencing Pikachu in
particular
the Eastman is fully electric just like
Pikachu is an electric type
so they're a perfect match
uh is there an overarching motto to this
partnership
so indeed there it is we asked ourselves
the question what is if a car could
connect it with your gaming console just
like it does with your smartphone
so we are promoting a playful mindset
just like our brand and Pokemon
so our Gamescom claim is play on never
stop playing well speaking of never stop
playing will we see you next year at
Gamescom as well yeah we plan to stay in
the game and play on for sure like we
always have from the get-go so stay
tuned awesome all right Oliver thank you
so much we've got much more owenl still
to come
dark tide is a first person Co-op game
set in the Grim dog future of Warhammer
40 000.
welcome to tertia a sprawling Hive City
on the brink of Destruction
you are a reject a convict free to serve
the Inquisition in this darkest of ours
it is your duty to fight and if
necessary die for the emperor
you can expect no help
s you
last line of defense
later
[Music]
is about to begin
rejects will rise
[Music]
once upon a time there were two twin
sisters
Torah and Yaga
you got it all
[Music]
at all stop it you can't hide from Baba
princess I'm how much longer you want to
be a nobody I just need to find the red
oak what you really want to find this
the hut
what the hell is wrong with this Forest
[Music]
bad
ly kill it again
if anything bad happens
always head straight to the Red Oak
foreign
Bull gives you wings
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
and now it is time for a final award but
don't worry there is more on Saturday so
make sure to not miss our award show on
Saturday but here are your nominees for
the Most Wanted Sony PlayStation game
the dark pictures The Devil in Me
lies of P
one piece Odyssey
foreign
ER is lies of P
here to accept the award is G1 Choi
Project Director Ed Neil is the stage is
yours
oh thank you
um
I'm very proud of my team members and uh
we always do our best to live up to the
our team's name the North and finally do
you know BTS Like BTS in Korean pop
we'll be done off in the Korean gaming
industry
thank you
thank you congratulations once again to
Liza P thank you so much and yes that's
it from me too for tonight but before I
say goodbye I want to bring your
attention to a more serious matter the
past five months of War have been
devastating for the Ukrainian families
and UNICEF and partners on the ground
are supporting those in needs and of
course funds are needed so please
consider donating at unicef.org if it's
possible and um yes we have to take care
of each other Gamescom also supports the
development of antura the language
learning game for Ukrainian children and
tour is based on an app which was made
for a Syrian War refugees to learn the
local language and I mean in times like
this it is more important than ever to
take care of each other and I hope you
keep that in mind not only for Gamescom
this week but way after thank you so
much that's it from me and have
wonderful games come Jeff back to you
thank you melody great to have you with
us we got a few more games to go now one
of the great things about gamescoms we'd
love to profile games made in Germany
and this next game was made by four
students in Berlin it was a big success
on Steam and now it's coming to a new
platform and we've got the announcement
right now
[Music]
cute beautiful now we're gonna get dark
the Outlast trials you guys excited for
this game the Outlast trials we showed
you last year at Gamescom open Night
Live and we haven't heard anything
sensorly from the team and everyone
keeps asking me when are we going to get
to play this well tonight we've got the
world premiere of the brand new trailer
and yes some news
on when you might get to play it here we
go
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
foreign
dispensing of existence
by the promise of execution
that's right some people will get to
play something this year the Outlast
trials all right next up we've got a
tease of the first release from Embark
Studios which a lot of the veterans that
worked on the battlefield franchise in
Stockholm Sweden they've got a shooter
wrapped in a game show format where
destruction is going to play a key role
what we've got here is a short tease
with some actual gameplay in it the full
reveal is coming later in September you
can sign up starting now to get in to
start Play tests of this check out the
finals
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
we got one more game for you tonight at
Gamescom Opening Night Live and this is
one we've all been waiting
a long time for Here We Go
[Music]
foreign
oh
it's
true Dead Island 2 coming next February
and joining me now to tell us about this
long-awaited game is Khan Khan Great to
uh to have you with us first of all
let's explain a little context to that
trailer we saw who is that character
that we meet
thank you Jeff it's great to be here uh
so you just met Jacob and he is just one
of our six playable characters our
zombie Slayers have Larger than Life
personalities and unique dialogue which
fits in with a very pulpy and irreverent
tone as you could tell I see the tag
line there uh see you in hell a so it
looks like we're heading to uh to Los
Angeles in this game well our pulpitone
is kind of a love letter to Classic cult
Hollywood horror B movies so where
better to set it than in Los Angeles uh
sort of a modern Paradise gone to hell
oh yeah it looks uh looks cool and it's
obviously over the top uh I know you're
working on the narrative for it uh this
game has been you know long awaited for
many many years that you guys have been
working on it for a few yeah I'm sure
some fans would agree with you it has
been long awaited but uh Deep Silver Dam
Buster Studios started work on it about
four years ago we were really lucky we
got to build it from the ground up we
got to focus on what we love about the
franchise the over-the-topness and
um we think we've got a really great
action RPG out of that so let's talk
about the gameplay we saw that CG piece
obviously but what can we expect from
the gameplay when you show it so Dead
Island 2's gameplay is all about
experimenting with your preferred zombie
slaying methods just kind of going nuts
it's a combat toy box of Close Quarters
melee brutality with a few guns for fun
okay well I can't wait to learn more
when are we going to get to see more see
some game Planet you want to see some
gameplay I think we want to see some
gameplay you guys want to see the
gameplay
can we do it now how about now okay
let's do it here's your first look at
the gameplay of Dead Island 2. thanks
God
foreign
yeah
this way for the happy ending Jimmy
[Music]
survival depends on the Red Bull pumping
through my veins well
sounds like you're the star of the show
now this mocker
boom
got your whiskey
not have this devil in my house
[Music]
gosh this is beyond insane
thank you
and believe it or not there is an uncut
version that trailer you can watch
online if you want to see even more all
right well that's Dead Island 2. coming
in February and that is going to wrap up
all the reveals for Gamescom Opening
Night Live
2022. uh it's been a fun show but before
we go I just want to say I hope everyone
has a great Gamescom there's lots of
live streams for the next couple days
lots of things for you guys to go and
play and check out here on the show
floor and as for me and the team well
we're going to go back to Los Angeles
and get ready for the game awards 2022
which I'm excited to announce will be
live on Thursday December the 8th 2022
from the Microsoft theater in Los
Angeles we've got lots of great stuff
we're working on for that but until then
hope you guys have a great Gamescom
thanks so much for being a part of
Opening Night Live we'll see you soon
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
coverage of Gamescom
2022 that was Jeff Healey with Opening
Night Live I'm Lucy James and join again
bye Timo Hussein hello Gamescom it's
Gamescom and Kurt in Davina
all right
uh I mean before we get into the kind of
nitty-gritty rundown what did you both
think of the show
I thought it was good
um expectations were properly managed by
Young Jeff ahead of this
um so we didn't go in there expecting
crazy crazy things but there were just
enough cool things and surprises for us
to kind of get excited about but not
mind-blowing in by any measure
um I think very heavy on CG uh footage
this year
um feels like the main the main themes
where we've got a lot of CG footage and
we've got a lot of space games and uh it
sure did deliver on those two parts
first and foremost Space games have been
the ongoing thing for the past what
since game awards there's a space game
Space game Space horse some of game Fest
was uh from the space Festival like
summer space Fest but we did get you
know we did uh for what it's worth
actually get a little bit more of Life
Of Lies of P I keep wanting to call it
life of people
lies of pee uh we did actually get like
a good I mean we've seen gameplay of it
already but we got a big old
chunker more of it and we actually did
see Dead Island too and we saw Crystal
protocol gameplay which is exactly what
I wanted to see like a glimpse or at
least like a little a little walk in the
footsteps of what the game is like but
yeah lots of CG but still
a wink and a nod
okay let's let's start with lies of P
there because you you brought it up
um you know you both love bloodborne uh
what did you make of this one I also had
a really stupid moment in the middle of
it where I just went oh the P stands for
Pinocchio
[Music]
unfortunately for me I wasn't being
completely serious I know I thought I
thought it looked really cool but I
defer to you two as the as the black
born fans Tamp you obviously come on
yeah I mean I think it looks really
cool already interesting I think the the
tricky thing is like when you are a fan
of
um from games like you're always chasing
that high and there's nothing quite as
disappointing as get looking at a game
and thinking oh this could scratch that
edge and then ultimately finding out
that it doesn't really we have a lot of
those games past and present and I have
a pretty good radar for them and I
usually am pretty good at tuning them
out and I for the most part will do that
however this one it feels like it's kind
of punched through a bit more it feels
like it's not just trying to ape um what
from does it's got It's a mixture of
like its own ideas and some of
Inspirations from them I really like
that they have a fundamental kind of
like
World theme and aesthetic to it that
they are kind of working off of
um the whole like Pinocchio side of it
is really clever really smart way to
kind of put a spin on something that
people know and and you know most people
who know Pinocchio know it for it's kind
of Disney
um uh version where it's kind of like
you know colorful and very upbeat and
it's a story about becoming a real boy
and all that kind of business and this
is kind of taking that and almost
injecting a like a cosmic horror element
to it not actually Cosmic horror but
like when you look behind the curtain of
something and see something way more
horrifying that is what lies of P feels
like it's doing like behind the curtain
of Pinocchio is something way worse and
there's a lot of uh Beyond like the vibe
and the aesthetic of the city it's like
a mixture of Gothic and also like
futuristic there's a lot of like
electricity stuff happening a lot of
like
um
mechanical arm stuff and characters at
one point you see what looks like it
seems like you're playing as Pinocchio
um but that remains to be confirmed
because at one point you know there's
there's that man there who is like um
it's good to see you again son who I
assume yeah I see Miss Geppetto but who
knows
um but like there's a cast of characters
and they all seem like they have a part
to play there's some weird like um
ability stuff happening with it and
combat stuff I really want to see more
of um yeah it's exciting it's one of
those games that like I said as a
incredibly cynical Souls alike person
who is more often than not will not
enjoy Souls like games
um is one that has like definitely
piqued my attention in the same similar
way to kind of like thymesia has
recently where um there's something
going on with that game that's worth
checking I I feel like lies of p is
another one of those games where it's
like all right I'm gonna keep an eye on
this hmm okay what'd you make of it I
will say I was like uh I've been
extremely skeptical of this game but I
think it's because we've seen so many
Souls clones uh and not saying that's
like I mean for some good stuff that
exists that have done it well this one
in particular first when I was tell us
about it this is just like a bloodborne
reskin but not even that it was like but
it just kind of changed the characters
made them more
really did make me a little bit more
optimistic at least I wasn't maybe on
the same I was maybe on the same size
Tam being a little cynical be like yeah
I mean I would love to just get a new
bloodborne but this is just going to
feel like this is going to be just
something that feels like a hole that
I'm just like yeah but this isn't one
bloodborne too that aside uh cutting out
a little bit
so I'm just gonna pause you right there
until your internet comes back I'm sorry
we'll come back to it but we can't
really hear you I'm so sorry we'll come
back
robocurt has joined us I can't tell if
he's crashed there if he's just being
very very still
I'm here
you are a robot okay I'm afraid sorry
mate
um you can figure that out maybe see if
you've got any streams or something
going I will I will go to Tam uh we
talked a little bit about Sonic
Frontiers before we started
um did this trailer do enough to change
your mind I I feel like I'm caught in
this I'm still very much aware and and I
feel like we're still in the Sonic cycle
of it where it's like yeah the trailer
looked good like the the gameplay stuff
looked good uh you know it looked like
uh they had some actual like crafted and
curated areas that uh you can go into in
between the open world like part of it
which is the open World part of it is
mostly what we've seen thus far and it
looked that is the thing that a lot of
people were reacting to where it's like
it seems desolate it seems kind of empty
and it seems kind of not at all engaging
game Wise It's like random hovering
structures that you kind of run around
and go up to and whereas the stuff that
we saw today was a little more like oh
this is like a Sonic Adventure style
area
um the interesting thing for me is like
I think it's taking itself very
seriously which anytime Sonic takes
itself seriously is not good it's not a
good time
um but I think there's uh at one point I
think someone tells Sonic that he can't
stop running he can't run forever and
I'm like I don't know man that's kind of
his deal he just runs pretty much all
the time non-stop pretty quickly and so
I've heard
um but yeah I don't know there's like
um
there's like
promise to it
um but I'm still not convinced
um I think that a self-serious tone is a
Miss for me right now
um but we'll see how it goes maybe it'll
be fun
I mean like I said earlier I'm not
really a sonic person
a trailer didn't really do
me but you know the
the November 8th
what do we think about that one sooner
or later we'll know
um if it's good or not but I don't know
it's it's dangerously close to another
video game that probably
there's less skepticism around yeah so
um
uh good luck to Sonic in his future
endeavors oh I've and also sorry to cook
because his his internet is completely
messed up but I love how he's kind of
can we leave him on the screen like that
just looking so different am I just not
here
you're Frozen completely Just Let It Go
Just I mean you can't leave the call
because you'll mess up the Discord
layout unfortunately it's like you hear
me
you got you gotta stop talking you gotta
stop talking
[Laughter]
all right we'll get going Tom another
surprise
well no the last one wasn't just
surprised but we got an actual surprise
here the Lords of the Fallen
they are back
I mean
I I honestly didn't expect to see this
one Lords of the Fallen was a game where
came out like what 2013 2014 didn't
really set the world on fire and then
they said they were making a new one
they set up a whole new team it was a
bunch of the folks who worked on Just
Cause 3 and then that one kind of got uh
people folks left the project got
rebooted and now it looks like we have
the Lords of the Fallen yeah it's been
like eight years or something like that
now yeah yeah uh I mean another game
that takes inspiration from from
software and Dark Souls the original
Lords of the Fallen that would have been
a better segue wouldn't it yeah I know
um but you know we we do what we can
here we've got robot Kurt falling apart
we got no Coffee Brains for both of us
um but yeah another game that's inspired
by
um the impeccable works of from software
uh the original Lords of the Fallen was
one of those games that when it first
showed up as it I think of it as one of
the early days Souls likes that gathered
a lot of like um kind of attention
because it looked super polished it
looked really really interesting it
looked like there was a lot going on
with it and unfortunately none of that
kind of bore out when people played it
it was like kind of not great
um didn't feel good to play kind of a
empty
um uh kind of shell of a Souls like
however it did attract enough attention
as a lot of clout around the IP a lot of
people did buy it and play it and some
people liked it I guess it was
definitely enough for them to double
down on a sequel this feels like they
are thinking about the world at least
way more we've seen none of the gameplay
so
um
hard to say what's going to go on but
there's some interesting stuff that you
can take away from that CG trailer with
the lamp that he's holding which seems
to be like siphoning energy off enemies
which could be a really cool combat
mechanic that if they that's one thing
that a lot of souls like developers
haven't done yet like tying kind of the
revive and Resurrection mechanic to
something that you do more closely in
combat
um the closest we get is like sekiro um
which has you know the the death blows
kind of charging that kind of stuff but
um yeah I'm excited for it I want to see
gameplay uh I think like what separates
this and lies of P at this point is we
got the CG trailer for layers of p and
it was like cool this looks interesting
and now we've got the Gameplay trailer
for lies of p and it looks like oh okay
they've they've got some stuff going on
here as it stands Lords of the Fallen
all we've seen is a CG trailer so I'm
gonna Reserve judgment and skepticism
levels will be readjusted based on when
we see
um the actual gameplay episode levels
will be readjusted accordingly uh yeah
it's I mean it was a good trailer but I
I kind of wish to see some of that
gameplay like you I I'm all I always
take uh CG trailers with a kind of a big
grain of salt which is why I was very
very happy to see when we looked at
Callisto protocol we got a good chunk of
gameplay and
I mean this with the utmost respect and
the fact that I'm excited for the game
it was exactly what I expected it to be
it looked great it looked like
methodical gruesome it looked like it
was gonna scare the crap out of me I was
very into it what'd you make of it yeah
I I pretty much exactly what you said
there was a nail on the head like it is
it's exactly what we kind of want it to
be and it doesn't really need to it
seems like they've got some interesting
like there's a Dodge mechanic in there
now it seems like at one point he
doesn't call the main character there's
a cool little
um little shimmy to get away from the
enemy but in in uh in pretty much every
other way it felt like a dead space game
you know like using the
um kind of uh powers to lift the enemies
and Chuck them into rotating blades and
Brew all combat um I think there was
your character looked like he was really
taking a beating so I I do wonder about
the fragility or like the survival
horror nature of it and whether it's a
little more skewed towards action or it
could be simply a case of like for the
purposes of this trailer we're gonna you
know make him basically unkillable and
so he can take a beating
um but yeah in terms of I got a little
bit of what I wanted which was
atmosphere like I got a vibe to it it
wasn't overbearing there was no lot of
music happening you can just hear a lot
of breathing and desperate struggling
and like slushing of blood and sinew
out of context just a lot of breathing
there's a lot of breathing a bit of
blood and seeing you that's what I need
in my games I
I hope I am you are okay
come back quick test about what you
thought about Calista broker before you
turned over again
mad a moment ago because I actually had
something to say about laser P it
doesn't matter
no we can we can go for Liza P it looks
like it has a story
what do you mean it looks like it has a
story what are you saying about
bloodborne no what I'm saying is it
looked the thing that got me excited or
interested in Liza P that separated from
other Souls like in bloodborne is that
it wasn't taking a cryptic approach to
telling a story it was taking a much
more Forefront cinematic version it
looked like they were like cut scenes
like jumping through windows and stuff
but no one cares about that anymore
because we have moved on to another game
that I care about well thank you oh you
do care about this one what do you
reckon about Callisto do you like what
you saw
I uh admittedly I think I just agree
with you Lucy I saw exactly what I kind
of was expecting to see in a good way
um
so I will say I don't know if either one
of you mentioned this yet because I was
too eager having like a temper tantrum
by myself in my mind
um I kind of Last of Us combat Vibes yes
I was actually thinking that a little
bit uh um which was unusual yeah which
was unusual to see in in like the what
we would
are we what we're so used to seeing and
that was actually kind of like a relief
to see that it's like yes you have your
your like your UI that just looks like
dead space you have your abilities like
pull things to you and throw it into
meat grinders that are just kind of
conveniently placed for you to do that
um but then I was like oh it's like you
can you can Crouch that's exciting you
could sneak up and you know do a little
of that and this and that so yeah it
gave me last of us Vibes it gave me like
um more so than I anticipated to see so
that was cool to see hi I have things to
say
honestly I agree with you there and
honest
and honestly like I will have a chance
instead of just like freaking out if I
can even the playing field a little bit
with stealth then that is 100 my bag
let's talk a little bit about uh I I
honestly didn't expect a new
dual sense Edge I didn't know what that
was
okay you know what I'm just gonna say it
it sounds a little bit like a name for a
sex toy Jewel sends Edge the Dual Sun's
already did kind of you know I mean yeah
but I like I
said so many times on podcast shows
whatever that I absolutely love the
Elite Series 2. it is one of my favorite
controllers I
and and while I love the Dual sense you
know I don't have the the flexibility
to to make it how I want it and I'm not
even I'm not even that particular I
don't think but like you know I have
certain uh things that I have changed
like I have really bad repetitive strain
injury and so being able to use back
pedals is super super great for me
um and I've always been a little bit sad
that PlayStation has never done the same
thing but now it looks like they are
looks like a highly customizable I did
see like little
flaps for the back
um you're using flaps on your dual sets
are you
I might
what did you guys make of it dual Sun's
edge with the flaps yeah I mean it makes
it makes it makes perfect sense that
they wouldn't make one of these at this
point like the the demand for it is is
really high and can make a lot of money
off selling premium controllers
um but yeah based on the stuff that
they've shown it looks like it's got all
the fundamentals that you need from it
for a pro-ish controller
um a customizable control stuff like
profile stuff that you can save
um and then there's like dedicated
buttons to like help you adjust things
uh
um a kind of its own like UI style thing
and it's got like diff changeable stick
caps and back buttons and replaceable
modules and that kind of stuff so uh for
all us all us like weird controller
weirdos um to get excited about is it
looks like it's got everything there and
it still looks nice I like the way the
Dual sense looks
um so I'm glad they're not like
switching it up too much
um we they showed off the white one I'm
interested to see whether they'll have
like other colors because since they you
know released the dual SIM so now put
out a bunch of different colors for that
controller so
hopefully they have more than just a
white one and black one
uh my dual sense like crunches in my
hands like even when I pick it up like
if I breathe on it the wrong way it like
it's like kind of like winces at me
um so I'm a little concerned about its
life
so if there is a solution for a dual
sense edge with the flaps
um that doesn't feel like it's gonna
crunch like just disintegrate my hands
at any moment
I'm here for it
hell yeah uh let's talk about and some
of the other new things that we gotta
look at I mean let's talk about hideo
kojima's Spotify series yes uh let's
talk about that faith you know of all
the Kojima things I you know you can
never really predict what he's gonna do
next and I really did not have him doing
a podcast series called brain structure
uh down Tam what time would you make of
it I I'm excited for it um people may
forget me have forgotten but he this
isn't the first podcast that Kojima has
had back in the day he used to do the
Koji Pro podcast
um those were I think that launched post
Metal Gear Solid three pre-medical solid
four and it kind of was an update on it
was it was your regular check-in with
the team
um at kojuma Productions to to talk
about what they were up to and it was
honestly a lot of talking about Monster
Hunter
um because they were all obsessed with
monster hunter at the time
um but they also used to drop in tidbits
about
um game the games that they were the
game that we're working on and also a
lot of the stuff that they liked and
were consuming that you know at the time
uh while making the games and honestly
like if that's what this is if they just
talk a little bit more about you know
what Kojima likes and he gets to talk to
people creators whether they're in the
games industry or the music industry or
movies TV whatever I'm up for that like
there's a lot of cynicism and a lot of
people take the piss with Kojima but
like the man is enthusiastic about stuff
in a way that I wish I could be
maintained on a daily basis like you
look at a piece of bread and be like
this is awesome bread here's my amazing
bread I made toast today and it's good
or he'll like take a screenshot of his
what whatever bizarre music player he's
listening to and be like here is the low
raw song that I'm currently listening to
and it's the greatest thing in my life
and you know what I'm ready for that
energy in audio form I'm ready for him
to be excited about things I'm really
him for him to be like indulgent and
inspire you know other people to do the
same so yeah I'm down for it very nice I
I love at the moment how much he loves
Huey from the boys which is very very
wholesome Kurt you're gonna listen to
kojima's Spotify podcast uh first off
I'd
I don't really listen to podcasts so if
it was like 10 minutes and Nicholas
winning reference was on it I would
consider tuning in but as far as I'm
concerned I don't think he actually
works I don't know if Kojima is actually
working because all he does is take
pictures
well then well he also is like an
influencer on the side because like
people like dude this is always sending
him like boxes of stuff and he's like
taking like time I'm not saying that it
consumes a lot of time in your day but
like
he has a team of people taking those
pictures for him and he's trying to take
his pictures himself
he came
Uggs there was an Entourage mate well I
saw that but is he is he just like
pulling records out be like here take
pictures of this no he had like his own
cinematographer
do you remember yeah
in the car on the way out he they he
that guy had already like edited
together a video of their day at our
office and then uploaded it like he has
he has this online yeah he knows what
he's doing like I bet you he just like
picks up a sandwich and someone is
whoever's there is like picture and he's
like sure whatever and then he does I do
I will say I was really hoping he was
gonna put on an album if I if Kojima
moved into like the music space and
started doing like what David Lynch did
and came out with a bunch of albums out
of the blue I would have lost my mind if
he did if he did if he did music I could
there's one thing I can say it is 100 at
the very least will be better than
anything Jeremy Renner has produced in
his lifetime in a studio
gotta tell you exactly so I'm down for a
could you putting Jeremy Renner and
Kojima like in the same space
is the music Jeremy Wren is one of them
yeah yeah it wouldn't make sense I was
really hoping for the Kojima album but
instead I hope brain structure is just
subliminal
um ways to announce things that we don't
know are coming I mean people are gonna
read into it stupid I don't know anyway
I'm gonna play every episode in Reverse
that's the only way I'll listen to it I
hope it's just like ASMR and he just
like it's just Kojima gently lulling you
into sleep just being like you want to
go sleep no and then you launch into
something about nuclear proliferation
and you're like okay cool I can do this
uh we had a lot of announcements
um let's start I mean let's talk a
little bit about uh everywhere which is
the new game from Lindsay Lindsay Leslie
benzie's uh formerly of Rockstar Games
um what did you make of that one this
one opened the show
that show did look like a game about
everything and nothing that you could
very easily use the words
verse and perhaps blockchain and nft
around I hope that's I I can't I can't
say whatever for sure it is any of those
but man they're like
the energy coming off of it I was like I
I reached the stage in my life where I
want a singular focused vision for your
game as opposed to this is everything
you can do anything here because guess
what I will not be doing anything when
it's everything it's nothing so I don't
know it looks kind of cool you can
race ATVs and then you're a third person
shooter and then it's Crackdown and then
it's uh you you PlayStation home and
cool man I mean the the uh elephant in
the room here is it looked a little
fortnighty oh yeah yes I mean it looks
like everything all at once I have
nothing to say about it because I have
absolutely no idea what it was and even
when they were trying to say like that's
a lot to talk about they're like yeah
sure is like yeah it is and that was the
end of the conversation so what is what
yeah what is that's what I want
developers to do now if you're coming on
stage with one of these things you
better have like a follow-up pitch that
is like a tweet or less that can
summarize what your game is if it is one
of these weird fortnite style like we're
trying to shove everyone in here and
make it everything
bizarre everything everywhere all at
once I guess uh let's talk a little bit
about Monkey Island could I know you're
a big fan did you like what you saw
today with the free horse armor oh um
if I'm no I I
think he is still like the thing is is
like uh my reaction isn't like a
negative one it's like kind of to be
expected
um Ron Gilbert and his crew have become
like so forth while breaking
they always were but I feel like they've
it's been like launched into the
universe over the uh their past couple
of releases specifically thimbleweed
Park which was just like fourth wall
breaking the game so yeah I mean it's
like to me it was just uh a release
trailer it was just a release date
trailer which I'm happy about which I'm
happy that's fine it looks really cool
the eye looks really nice but uh the art
is fantastic I'm I'm slightly worried
about that humor now that they made a
horse armor joke in 2022 is like extreme
Boomer energy that is like that is Ron
Gilbert energy I mean yeah you're right
that's why that's why I say it with like
this isn't like a negative thing it's
just what I come what I think many
people should come to expect and even
something that may actually really
worried about
with return to Monkey Island because one
of my concerns and criticisms of
thimbleweed Park was like if you're not
an adventure game person or if let's
just say you you did you you missed the
the height of the Heyday of the genre
and you have no idea who Ron Gilbert is
then you I always was like I don't think
people will understand what thimbleweed
park is because it's constantly
referring to Ron Gilbert it's constantly
referring to other adventure games and I
think that's like
it should live on its own merits so that
is that has been an underlying concern
I've had with Richard Monkey Island in
general but that doesn't mean that I as
a fan
I'm not like looking forward to it but
I'm definitely like yeah we'll see what
the non Boomer even non-millennial
folks see think of that different voice
for stand though and yeah in um Monkey
Island not sure if I'm into it yet
we'll see it and we don't have one
wanting to wait before it comes out
of my highlights
um Moon breaker uh Brandon Sanderson the
man who does not sleep
um you know he listed off some of his
achievements uh and some of his works at
the beginning of that little trailer but
what I really liked it was that this is
the the one from the subnautica devs and
it was completely different it seems
like a like a tabletop Miniatures game
but also you get to paint them I texted
uh resident uh Miniatures enjoyer Dave
DeWitt on the game sport team and he
said I don't even have time to paint the
ones I have in real life but this looks
cool so what did you guys make of it I'm
very excited for it I cannot wait I love
a little Brandon Sanderson story I love
tactics games
um and I like to do art so these work
for me I've never done Miniatures but
it's the time Venn diagram yeah I've
never done Miniatures I've been very
careful about trying not to fall down
that hole but digital Miniatures I can
get on board with I just hope it's not
like how would you like to pay five
dollars for an extra color of pain next
for a new cynical yeah I hope it's none
of that but otherwise I'm excited to
play I really like the The energy they
had to it like with the it is like the
only thing missing was like the arms of
the kid or the person like smashing the
pieces together and being like Wham
um and it does look like it's got a kind
of
exuberance and a a
vivaciousness to the to the gameplay
which I'm interested in I'm going to be
painting the worst figures anybody's
ever seen whether they're not that's
intentional I can't tell you but I do
know I went down a rabbit hole when I
was like 10 years old Warhammer the one
and only time I ever did it when I was
like I can't afford this I'm young I
don't have money uh and I painted a
single set of like five neck rounds and
I was like they're the coolest thing but
I wouldn't be surprised knowing me I'll
get real impatient and just paint all
the black and gold it a day
I was also in to Warhammer for a very
brief amount of time when they released
the Lord of the Rings one so you know on
brand uh and also just one final cool
trailer that I want to talk about before
um I kind of ask you guys your favorite
picks and we'll talk about Dead Island
as well uh where winds
Meetup really cool trailer I was kind of
a bit worried at the beginning because
it looked like one of those like Tick
Tock adverts for like an episodic
Adventure
um but uh when they went inside the
Gameplay trailer a little mix of ghost
of tsushima and ghosts are Assassin's
Creed it looks really cool the epic
music as well
um and kind of a like a an otherworldly
sort of vibe to it like a bit
Supernatural that I really really
enjoyed uh what did you think of it
looks looks really cool um set in China
Northern Song Dynasty period
um yeah and mixture of like
fantasy and weird Dark Fantasy stuff um
the thing that I'm most interested in
seeing more of is the combat because it
looks like it's got a lot of weapon
based off blades and that kind of stuff
but it looks like there's a decent
amount of hand-to-hand combat as well
which is something that definitely not a
lot of
um these type of games try and like
really flesh out in a meaningful way
um so I'm excited to see how that comes
together it definitely is one of my
highlights of the show for sure I was
intrigued that was my interests peaked
it's one of those things I'll like keep
an eye on it had it had the uh it had
the Constitution thing it had a a
whisper breath of the wild I had a bit
of Assassin's Creed that we thought
while we were watching it at first
um but it's one of those like yeah that
was a surprise or at least in the sense
that's like I will remember to remember
that title I'm excited to know more uh
Tam otherwise what was one of your
highlights uh from the show
oh Beyond lies of p and where the winds
meet or where wins and meet whatever it
whatever it may be called
um I think like
um yeah I think we've talked about
pretty much everything that uh would be
would be those two games and then Moon
breaker
um I I thought was cool I mean like
Tales from Borderlands looks interesting
and I'm willing to pay a little more
attention to the laws of the Fallen but
those games plus also Dune Dune look oh
do you look like something uh we look
like a CG
um trailer again but a dune MMO could
have something going on with it
um it is from font com Age Of Conan
people and various other MMOs so they
know how to make a MMO
um but we'll see how that goes um yeah
that's pretty much it and Gotham Knight
is coming four days early oh yeah that
trailer that trailer looked great good
trailer that was a good trailer
um yeah they've had some shaky trailers
and and some weird moments in in their
kind of marketing campaign but that
trailer looked solid
okay what about you what are your
highlights from the show this might be a
surprise considering I've never seen the
show and I walked into the beginning of
this but like don't talk to me because I
have no idea what to say about it but
the expanse looked really sweet like
that looked like a uh like what it's
attached to a side since I I haven't
watched it
um we kind of went in or at least I
think what but you both said like oh
like Telltale needs to show something
that makes it look like they're going
beyond what your old engine was or their
old ex whatever was that you know how
they used to present their games and I
thought that was like it was a really
well presented stylistic like grounded
uh new approach to Telltale Games and
also like it was really cool to see a
more emphasis on like actual physical
exploration like actually pushing a
character through an environment and
going through space so I was actually
like really like damn like this is
actually I'm that was one of the only
trailers that stuck out to me no bias no
idea like really no attachment to the
expanse at all and I was like I want to
play this I'm interested in seeing what
this is and how uh telltale's seems like
they're taking a deliberate approach to
evolve what they're known for yeah I I
was stoked because I uh I love drama
she's probably my favorite character
from the expanse and the fact that you
know courage is in it and she's got
the cheekbones and like that that
character is incredible but I totally
agree with what you said like it just
looks
like the bit where she's climbing up the
ladder and like avoiding and exploring
the the world in in a more meaningful
way I really excites me so I'm very very
stoked for that one uh and yeah I guess
before we wrap up let's talk a little
bit about
Dead Island 2.
um I wasn't particularly wowed by the
trailer I think just I was expecting
something like a little more high energy
like the whole point of the character is
that he looked bored and I was like
that's not really enticing me as a
player that you're you're the main
character or one of the six main
characters is kind of bored and like the
zombie I get that they're trying to do
like oh the zombie apocalypse is just
your world now but
um there's no mistake in that yeah
there's no stake in that it's like you
just you know um and so I I kind of
enjoyed a little bit more when I went to
the gameplay a little bit uh higher
octane a little bit more
um what I would expect from Dead Island
um it seems like damn Busters they said
been working on it for four years
I'm still not like
I don't know
I just don't think this is gonna be one
for me I didn't see anything in that
game to make me think oh okay you're
doing this it's just it looks like I
could have written down everything I
have seen there and and done that based
on everything those kind of games have
been up until this point the most unique
thing that they talked about is the
setting which is like
okay
cool
um but we haven't admittedly we've seen
a small amount of it but I don't know
what they could do with that or would
kind of really turn me open world zombie
game where you've got a bunch of options
on how you kill zombies and there's
going to be a bunch of different zombie
types and you're in LA and everyone's
gonna be like weirdly making light of
the situation for comedy value
all right
good how'd you feel about it it exists
in a space
that serves a very like specific
audience and purpose I first I wouldn't
say I would put it somewhere with
Borderlands but I just feel like I
imagine like there's these audiences
that love Borderlands there's these
audiences that love first person
exploration games it's like I don't know
I even like think about maybe Far Cry is
doing a disservice but it's just like
there's just these big open world games
where you do things and you shoot stuff
and you have a good time doing it and
Dead Island 2 just seems that it's going
to be fitting in that space with all
those other things and that's totally
fine
um so it's I didn't see anything that
oh it put me in awe in its imagination I
did think like seeing that the the
environment seems to play a little bit
bigger of a role in the gameplay and how
like you like shot the gas thing out and
like you're like that thing on fire and
kick people in nothing we haven't seen
before but you know it's cool to see
that at least the world feels like it's
kind of
is working I guess like working its own
way so yeah I I'm I'm
unenthusiastically like sure cool that's
fine cool
um as well as the kind of
like pseudo
game you know Dead Island very similar
but they also fight yeah Dying Light
also found its audience
a dead and dying brilliant yeah
um all right that's it from us uh thank
you so much for joining us for the uh
pre and post show for Opening Night Live
we're gonna have a bunch of coverage
with a look at some of the new games
revealed at Gamescom so make sure to
subscribe to Gamespot and YouTube if you
haven't already and make sure to check
back to gamespot.com time where can
people find you you find me everywhere
Atmore H doing stuff
okay what about you you can find me
somewhere in San Francisco wandering in
the streets I'm sure you look you'll see
a linky pale dude doing high kicks
otherwise if you do feel any need to
follow me or see what it is that I'm
making at her underscore indovina that's
how you do that awesome and I'm on
Twitter at Lucy James games and we'll
see you next time